اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء قالت
وزاره للخزانه الامريكيه ان مجموعه فاغنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه تزود قوات الدعم
السريع بصواريخ ارض جو لمواجهه الجيش
السوداني كما اكدت الخزانه الامريكيه في
بيانها انها فرضت عقوبات على قائد مجموعه
فاغنر في مالي اذن
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر ان اليه مراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان كشفت عن انتهاكات محتمله
للاتفاق واضاف ان واشنطن اتصلت بطرفي
النزاع
قال رئيس جزر القمر الرئيس الحالي للاتحاد
الافريقي غزالي عثمان ان الحرب في السودان
خطيره لانها ستؤثر على قاره افريقيا
باكملها واكد عثمان في حديث خاص للجزيره
ان على طرفي الصراع في السودان ان يعلم
انه لا منتصر في هذه الحرب ولابد ان تتوقف
قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
العاصمه هجوما روسيا بصواريخ كروز استهدف
المدينه وان الدفاعات الجويه تتمكنت من
تدمير جميع الصواريخ واوضحت الاداره
العسكريه ان الهجوم هو الثالث عشر من نوعه
الذي يستهدف العاصمه من اجواء بحر قزوين
اعلنت هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت السد ذكر ليفكا
يوم امس الخميس باربعه صواريخ من طراز اس
300 واضافت الهيئه ان اصابه سد كارليفك
بالصواريخ يهدد بحدوث فيضان وغرق عدد من
البلدات المحيطه بالسد
اعلن وزير الدفاع
الامريكيين على الجيل الرابع من طائرات اف
16 قد يبدا خلال الاسابيع المقبله واضاف
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان الدنمارك وهولندا
ستقودان جهود تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على طائرات اف 16
افادت وكاله رويترز ان اليابان فرضت حزمه
عقوبات على 78 كيانا و17 شخصا من روسيا
واضافت الوكاله ان العقوبات تتضمن تجميد
اصول الكيانات والاشخاص وحذر توفير خدمه
البناء والهندسه
وصفات الخارجيه الامريكيه تجربه ايران
الصاروخيه الاخيره بانها تهديد للامن
الدولي واكدت ان الدبلوماسيه تبقى افضل
السبل لمنعها من حيازه سلاح النووي من
جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني ان
تقدما جيدا حصل بشان المفاوضات النوويه
وان تبادلا غير مباشر للرسائل جرى بين
طهران واشنطن بشانها
ختام هذا الموجز شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]